let's talk about Donald Trump's
conflicts of interest and this little
old thing called the Constitution which
many Trump voters claim to really
support we talked about how Donald Trump
said he would put his businesses into a
blind trust which of course exposed he
has no clue what that is because a blind
trust does not involve you knowing
exactly where your money is invested
read Trump's real estate of projects and
hotels etc and you don't know what
decisions are being made by the trustees
and since Donald Trump's own kids are
going to be the trustees there is
obviously a direct connection there and
there is nothing there that you would
call a blind trust we talked about this
ridiculous inclusion of Ivanka Trump in
a meeting with president-elect Donald
and the Japanese Prime Minister she is
not someone who is even legally allowed
to be part of trumps administration she
is not someone who has a security
clearance it's a disaster okay
now let's get to the legality of this
it's worth noting that Donald Trump is
poised to go against what the
Constitution says on day one in office
now this is not my opinion right this is
not progressive David Pakman who has
come up with this opinion this is the
opinion of george w bush's ethics lawyer
and I'll explain the Constitution does
not allow presidents to seek or receive
gifts from foreign agents Friday evening
as reported by the Washington Post about
a hundred foreign diplomats gathered at
president-elect Donald's hotel in
Washington DC to sip Trump branded
champagne dine on sliders and hear a
sales pitch from president elect Donald
about the newest hotel in Washington DC
and this included a tour of the hotel's
$20,000 a night townhouse suite and the
article in The Washington Post actually
says foreign diplomats said in no
uncertain terms that they would be
deliberately staying at Trump's hotel
when they're in DC in order to curry
favor with soon-to-be President Donald
here's a quote from one diplomat from an
Asian nation according to the Washington
Post
why wouldn't I stay at his hotel blocks
from the White
at his hotel blocks from the White House
so I can tell the new president I love
your new hotel isn't it rude to come to
his city and say I am staying at your
competitor does anybody realize what we
have here we have an incoming president
that is holding an event with foreign
leaders to solicit business to his hotel
from foreign governments and then we
have foreign agents diplomats elected
officials saying I would absolutely
accept the president elects inducement
for business in order to win political
favor with him as president staying at
the hotel pad as a foreign nation in
this context is considered a gift of
monetary value which as we heard from
Richard painter a University of
Minnesota law professor who was the
chief ethics counsel to President George
W Bush that would violate a provision of
the Constitution intended to prevent
exactly this well to its credit I mean I
don't think Donald Trump has much of an
idea of what's actually in the
Constitution now outside of the Second
Amendment he doesn't know about all
these specific clauses and that sort of
thing no like the First Amendment for
yeah if only he had borrowed a kaiser
khan's copy of the Constitution maybe
he'd be more educated on it that would
have been useful to him and we're
referring to the Constitution's
emoluments clause which provides that
quote no person holding any office of
profit or trust under the United States
shall without the consent of the
Congress except of any present emolument
office or title of any kind whatsoever
from any King prince or foreign state
the diplomats effort to seek favor from
Donald Trump by staying at his hotel
would absolutely be a gift this is what
george w bush's own ethics adviser has
said and that this is just absolutely
amazing it's not just george w bush's
former ethics adviser that thinks this
on twitter Harvard Law Professor
Lawrence tribe agrees with painter
tweeting out that Reid Judd legume
thread he's right
regarding the emoluments clause these
are not legally ambiguous situations
this is very very clearly not okay
how can Trump get out of this well
painter says the only good answer would
be that Trump sell the hotel to his kids
or give it to his kids legally and pay
the gift tax before his inauguration but
the thing is pet even if he does that
the kids still have direct access to
Trump we know Ivanka has been in
meetings with foreign leaders there's
nothing like a blind trust and there's
no reason to think Trump is going in
that direction because the guy doesn't
even know what the hell that is he
really should just step up and do the
right thing here I think that would be
in the public's best interest but how
amazing is that that on inauguration day
on the day that he swears to uphold the
Constitution he'll be violating it
foreign dignitaries in attendance who go
back and stay at his hotel yeah complete
contradiction it's it's unbelievable
that this is what's going on and this is
this is America this is Trump's America
today's program is made possible in part
by movement watches I am wearing my
movement watch today and the really cool
thing about movement washes is the
company was started by two Broke college
kids that just wanted to wear stylish
watches couldn't afford them and they
actually crowdfunded their company
similarly to how the david pakman show
has used crowdfunding over the years to
expand and grow what we do the movement
watches start at just 95 dollars if you
go to a department store and you want a
watch of this caliber equality and
design you're looking at four to five
hundred dollars and movement watches
figured out hey if we sell online we can
cut out the middleman and cut out the
retail markup and provide the best
possible pricing you can get 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns if you go to em VMT watches
dot-com slash Pakman that's PA que ma n
I picked this watch because I like the
design and the simplicity and minimalism
they have all sorts of different watches
that you can check out this is the time
to step up your watch game go to mV mt
watches dot-com / Pakman that's PA que
ma n